c'est non nous allons maintenant
procéder à l'audition du réquisitoire du
procureur général des proches de la
république
ça va saigner merci et bien mesdames et
messieurs les jurés
monsieur le pardon monsieur bré acteurs
excusez moi dans mon président et grand
public chéri
sous cette robe je cache
non nos organes m'a dit je faisais le
oui non c'est pas le dire comme ça pour
être procureur de la république
on en est pas moins homme d'ailleurs
c'est pas et c'est un homme accablé de
chagrin qui vous parle aujourd'hui
mesdames et messieurs les jurés
pourtant cette fin d'été est magnifique
les oiseaux chantent encore dans les
platanes ou parisien les femmes sont
belles
l'air est doux il y avait même un
je-ne-sais-quoi de guy reilles de pain
pendant l'exécution capitale à laquelle
j'ai eu la chance d'assister ce matin et
pourtant mon coeur est lourd
mon coeur est lourd et grande est ma
peine et c'est à cause de vous mon petit
jean louis comme c'est à cause de vous
oui je lave ou j'ai du chagrin à l'idée
de devoir sévir contre cet homme
mesdames et messieurs les jurés pour la
bonne raison que c'est un fils
d'industriel jeu déjà leader à mon dieu
les présidents présidents ou valve pays
où va le monde si les fils de bourgeois
renie en toute pudeur de castres se
mettent à se rouler dans la fange
nauséeuse ne devrait se vautrer que la
canaille loubards d'immigrés de nos
douteuses périphérie 96 94
ainsi vous est habité par le démon du
jeu jean louis trintignant et pas par
n'importe quel jeu ni la roulette bon
chic ni le baccara bon genre non
mesdames et messieurs les jurés
l'accusée joue au poker
ah là là quelle époque de voyous comme
dirait mon ami il va rompre le poker à
propos duquel l'accusé montre alain
montrant là un insupportable cynisme ne
craint pas de clamer qu'on devrait le
rendre obligatoire dans les écoles est
de dire dans le matin de paris du 30
mars 1979 je vous cite j'adore le poker
c'est un jeu de pure méchanceté où l'on
mise sur le désarroi des autres par
ailleurs dans ce même journal vous
ajoutez plus loin et ça c'est encore
plus grave
les sentiments violents n'existe que par
leur contraire c'est une notion
chrétienne qui m'est cher mais alors il
y à du gilles de rais dans cet homme là
alors déçu à monsieur trintignant que
vont penser de vous les braves petite
jeune fille de france qui gardait
jusqu'à l'heure de vous la douce image
rassurante du brave jeune premier
français que vont-elles pensée elle qui
serrait sur leur coeur dans un même élan
d'amour
la photo de l'accusé celle d'alain delon
et celle d' andré dassary droit à dieu
me tripote au claude m
adieu me dan dans quel monde vivons-nous
commandes expliqué mesdames et messieurs
les jurés qu'un garçon ici d'une famille
gardienne de nos vraies valeurs
une famille où les enfants ne mettait
pas les coudes sur la table allaient à
la messe et disait bonjour à la dame
comment expliquer disait qu'un garçon
d'hocine noble extraction est puis sera
valais ainsi au rang de la bête
encore que rares sont les bêtes qui
jouent au poker l'explication est
peut-être dans les lectures de jean
louis trintignant qui toute honte bue ne
craint pas d'affirmer aux échotiers
qu'il aime à lire baudelaire rimbaud
verlaine ou même apollinaire et guy des
cars direz vous eh bien non guy des cars
monsieur trintignant n'a pas le temps de
le dire
il préfère l'infâme verlaine verlaine
qui tenait son verre d'absinthe d'une
main tandis que de l'autre
je ne sais si j'ose il préfère rimbaud
fraimbault l'exalté rimbaud l'abscons
dans mon ami d'ali dame disait encore
hier
c'est marrant j'y comprends rien du tout
inquiet dallas et qui visait
on
préfère baudelaire baudelaire qui
s'illustra si bassement dans la marine à
voile et à vapeur
rappelez vous son alexandrins au combien
de marins 18 ça fait beaucoup
il préfère enfin guillaume apollinaire
de son vrai nom crauste au vide ce qui
vous voyez ce que je veux dire je
demande à la cour une certaine
indulgence pour l'accusé le fait qu'il
soit d'extraction bourgeoise constituant
à mon sens une circonstance atténuante
je propose 20 ans de prison tout seul ou
un temps avec mireille mathieu ou choix
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
etonnant non
[Musique]